obviously given what happened over the
summer the left has no credibility on
this i do not want to hear a
single lecture from the left about
political violence from the right
and i i don't want to hear it from guys
like mitt romney either
the squishy conservatives quote unquote
the republicans
who pretend to be conservative but
really all they do
is serve as stooges for the liberal
establishment i don't want to hear
one peep out of mitt romney mitt romney
marched over the summer with
black lives matter a marxist
organization that torched washington dc
among many other cities torched it there
were photos going around yesterday on
the internet of
all the chaos in washington dc buildings
on fire fire all over the streets you
can even see the washington monument
there
not on fire but in the midst of the fire
that photo wasn't from the trump rally
yesterday
that photo wasn't from the ride at the
capitol yesterday that was from
blm and mitt romney marched with that
organization
very sad yesterday a woman a woman died
she was a
a pro-trump demonstrator and she she
died and we'll get into that in just a
second
and that was it one death very very sad
one death how many deaths
during blm how many deaths was it
something like 30
and we have u.s senators who march with
that organization
lecturing conservatives actual
conservatives
about political violence i don't want to
hear it there is now we can say
political violence
all around not to the same degree but
there is still some
all around it is it is a disordered act
it is it is a violent act
to smash windows to break into a capital
to put the capital on lockdown you can't
do that
but i do do not do not send me any
lectures
from mitt romney no thank you if you
enjoyed that video be sure to hit the
subscribe button so everyone waiting
through the wasteland
of youtube knows that we've got the
absolute top content out there
you